welche geschichte des jahres 2020
präsentiert deiner meinung nach in
verdichteter form am besten den absurden
zustand der aktuellen weltpolitischen
lage nun wieder erst mit dieser
tausende von irakischen asylbewerber
belagern die weißrussische polnische
grenze ich meine das einfach mal einen
blick auf die landkarte
der irak ist hier weißrussland dort und
polen befindet sich an dieser stelle
also denkst du jetzt gerade auch an das
an was ich denke was zum teufel machen
iraker an der grenze zwischen
weißrussland und polen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die situation ist folgende zum
aufnahmezeitpunkt dieses videos halten
sich auch der weißrussischen seite
schätzungsweise 15.000 iraker aber auch
für iraner afghanen libanesen und so
weiter auf und täglich strömen hunderte
weitere hinzu sie alle wollen über die
sogenannte belarus heute in die
europäische union einreisen über jene
drei eu länder die das riesige glück
haben nachbarn von belarus zu sein polen
litauen und lettland
die du dir vorstellen kannst ist keines
dieser länder besonders glücklich über
diese situation man kann nicht gerade
von einer willkommenskultur sprechen
[Musik]
der wald ausbruch an der polnisch
weißrussischen grenze polnische
grenzbeamte schießen mit wasserwerfern
auf migranten die steine werfen genau
von der einen seite fliegen steine von
der anderen kommt die antwort in form
von und tränengas und klar gibt es unter
den migranten gewaltbereite männer die
versuchen grenzposten einzureißen
allerdings erklärten viele migranten
dass sie keine andere wahl hatten da sie
von belarussischen soldaten vor die wahl
gestellt worden entweder steine gegen
polnische grenzbeamte zu schmeißen oder
nicht nach minsk zurückzukaufen und
damit weiter draußen übernachten zu
müssen und eventuell zu erfrieren sie
berichteten außerdem davon dass
belarussische grenzsoldaten den grenzen
und symbolen gezielt mit
bolzenschneidern aufschneiden würden
deswegen wird polen seine grenze stärker
befestigen litauen beginnt mit dem bau
einer mauer und selbst die nato erwägt
ein eingreifen und all das ist innerhalb
nur eines monats passiert
tja auf der fast 1200 km langen grenze
zwischen weißrussland und der eu war so
viel los dass selbst die protagonisten
des neuen james bond films im vergleich
dazu verblassen würden und du wirst
wahrscheinlich sagen mag du machst eine
gigantische krise daraus aber plusminus
15.000 migranten sind doch zum beispiel
für deutsche verhältnisse keine so große
sache immerhin hat deutschland allein im
jahr 2015 mehr als eine million
asylsuchende aufgenommen und tut dies
auch weiterhin tja was merkel scholz
oder berbalk nicht mal einen
wimpernzucken wert wäre trag dem
polnischen premierminister den blutdruck
gewaltig in die höhe meine damen und
herren ich wende mich an sie weil europa
unser gemeinsames haus bedroht ist wie
du siehst ist das was an polens ganze
passiert eine regelrechte
kriegserklärung und wenn herr moratti
vor zwei monaten noch sagte dass die eu
ihn erpresst appelliert er jetzt an
brüssel und an gemeinsame werte
denn zum zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses
videos haben bereits zwei polnische
grenzschützer und sitze kranken ihr
leben verloren dieser winter verspricht
sehr sehr hart zu werden 14 jähriger
junge stirbt an der weißrussischen
grenze an erkältung der migranten in der
eskalierenden krise als waffe
missbraucht werden und die fragen die du
dir vielleicht stellt den ersten von wem
werden sie als offenes braucht wer ist
der bösewicht in dieser geschichte der
böse drahtzieher hinter all dem 2 wie um
alles in der welt kommen iraker bis an
die grenze zwischen polen und
weißrussland
drittens wo befinden sie sich jetzt und
wie wird das alles wohl ausgehen ist
dies eine jener geschichten an die wir
uns morgen nicht mehr erinnern werden
oder wird das alles langfristige
übergeordnete folgen haben über welche
wir uns ernsthafte sorgen machen sollten
heute dann der selbstverständlich all
diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
möchten wir die den sponsor unseres
heutigen videos vorstellen
cpm ein wirklich sicheres nicht anders
wie der datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf websites
und internet dienste zugreifen die in
dem land den wir gerade seid nicht
verfügbar sind ohne zensur und geo
blocking ob daheim oder im urlaub
netflix und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten von
europa aus nutzen mit surf shorts kein
problem darüber hinaus bietet es jedoch
auch eine menge sicherheitsfeatures habt
ihr nicht zum beispiel auch ein mulmiges
gefühl durch die allgegenwärtigen der
hip hop soul cookies bezirk bekommt ein
handliches tool namens klien wird dass
sie alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem schlag und
ihr könnt ihr alle eure geräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
euren smart tvs deckt wirklich alle
arten von geräten ab ihr bekommt damit
einen lückenlosen schutz so und wenn ihr
den rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt
ihr von surf schlag auch noch ein rabatt
von 83% und obendrein die ersten vier
monate gratis dazu den link zu diesem
angebot findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video also nichts wie los
besorgt euch serge haag und greift damit
gleichzeitig auch ohne es finanziell
unter die arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit hilfe eines paypal
spenden links den ich ebenfalls in die
beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hält die uns euch in zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere videos zu liefern
so und nun zur migranten krise an der
polnisch weißrussischen grenze um sie
besser zu verstehen werden wir nämlich
zuerst einen kurzen blick auf die
geschichte
der mann der ein superschurke sein
wollte
ich weiß dass einige von euch denken da
muss doch auch russlands seine finger im
spiel haben putin ist auch an allem
schuld egal ob's wetter schlecht ist
oder die ehefrau mal wieder migräne hat
aber mit beiseite wir reden hier über
weißrussland ein land das die fäden der
internationalen politik normalerweise
nicht alleine zieht und in der tat gibt
es leute die sagen dass alles was jetzt
an der weißrussischen grenze passiert
teil von putins großen masterplan ist
europa zu stabilisieren um russland
wieder groß zu machen um die
weltherrschaft an sich zu reißen aber
die wahrheit ist das ist zumindest
technisch gesehen wenig sinn macht dass
diese krise in weißrussland von moskau
aus gesteuert wird außerdem wäre es
nicht das erste mal dass weißrussland
sich gegen die interessen seines großen
bruders russland auflehnt in dieser
geschichte sieht ist also so aus als ob
sich herr lukaschenko auf einem kleinen
ego chip befindet aber wer ist
eigentlich lukas schenkung nun er ist
der letzte große diktator in europa
[Musik]
und obendrein und versucht er gar nicht
mal so wie manch anderer herrscher diese
tatsache zu verschleiern dann ist quasi
noch stolz darauf und sollte jemals
irgendwer auf die idee kommen einen
feiertag für diktatoren einzuführen
würde lukaschenko den zugehörigen
festumzug voller android anführen es ist
besser ein diktator zu sein als schwul
erklärt der weißrussische präsident ja
das ist richtig so ist alexander
lukaschenko nun mal manche kinder wollen
astronauten oder youtuber werden er
wollte diktator sein und er hat es auch
geschafft manchmal bin ich neidisch auf
mich selbst ich bin der letzte und
einzige diktator europas du hast den
mann gehört das ist mich noch deutlicher
sagen alexander lukaschenko ist man da
schon immer ein superschurke sein wollte
[Musik]
und was diesen plan angeht hat er sich
gar nicht mal so schlecht geschlagen er
ist der diktator eines landes mit neun
millionen einwohnern geworden er kam vor
27 jahren an die macht und genießt ist
so sehr dass erst wenn irgendwie möglich
für immer bleiben möchte und da es in
belarus einem stetig wachsenden teil der
bevölkerung gibt der nicht zu gerne in
einer diktatur lebt das regime in minsk
in den letzten jahren die zügel immer
fester angezogen erstens durch ein
demonstrationsverbot an der tagesordnung
sind hohe geldstrafen verhaftungen
polizei schikanen und verschiedene
aktive repression zweitens durch die
einschränkung der pressefreiheit
bis heute wurden viele medien verboten
oder in weißrussland geblockt wir
sprechen hier von einer regelrechten
offensive
weißrussische journalisten kommen für
zwei jahre ins gefängnis weil die
proteste live gestreamt haben gut punkt
biopsie lawn eine nachrichtenseite die
von mehr als 40 prozent der
belarussischen internet nutzer gelesen
wird wurde gesperrt und die redakteure
verhört nachdem ihre büros und häuser
von den behörden durchsucht worden waren
in anbetracht all dessen sollte es nicht
überraschen dass weißrussland das land
mit den geringsten grad an
pressefreiheit in ganz europa ist ja es
ist sogar noch schlechter dran als die
türkei und du kannst dir wahrscheinlich
vorstellen wie politik in diesem land
funktioniert
[Musik]
die letzten präsidentschaftswahlen im
august letzten jahres statt am anfang
sah ist überraschend gut aus lukas
schenk war offensichtlich der haupt
kandidat aber auf der vorläufigen
version der stimmzettel standen auch
mehrere namen von oppositionellen die in
der bevölkerung unterstützung fanden und
es gab sogar analysten die sagten seht
her vielleicht ist es zeit für einen
übergang einen neuen präsident und
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen demokratie
in weißrussland
[Musik]
du kannst dir wahrscheinlich schon
denken wie das ganze dann trotz des
großen demokratie theaters ausgegangen
ist belarus verbietet zwei
oppositionskandidaten die teilnahme an
den wahlen
weißrussische oppositionelle vor der
präsidentschaftswahl inhaftiert
weißrussische wahlen oppositionsführerin
teams kaya ging ihren kindern zuliebe
die wir vorstellen kannst reichten am
wahltag wieder proteste noch
internationaler druck aus um auch nur
ein minimum an transparenz zu
gewährleisten und so begann lukaschenko
seine sechste amtszeit diktatorischer
denn je um es klar zu sagen heute sitzen
bis zu 800 politische gefangene in
weißrussischen gefängnissen und niemand
ist sicher denn lukaschenko regime hat
sehr sehr lange arme
schau dir das so einfach eine der
skurrilsten nachrichten dieses jahres an
ryanair flug mit einem opposition
journalisten an bord wird zur landung in
weißrussland gezwungen ja das stimmt
unter dem vorwand einer der festen
trauung hat weißrussland ein ryanair
flugzeug entführt das von griechenland
nach litauen fliegen sollte um einen
oppositionellen journalisten am boden
verhaften und ins gefängnis stecken zu
können ja ein flugzeug von ryanair wenn
du also das nächste mal mit einer billig
fluggesellschaft fliegt beschwer dich
nicht und er sitzt nicht bequem ist oder
du deinen koffer nicht mit an bord
nehmen darfst sei einfach dankbar dass
lukaschenkos luftpiraten ein flug nicht
gekapert haben ich für meinen teil werde
nach diesem video ganz sicher jedes mal
bevor ich ein flug antreten checken ob
er licht über weißrussisches territorium
führt paranoid nur wenn der arme
journalist lieber einmal mehr paranoid
gewesen wäre würde jetzt nicht für jahre
in einem weissrussischen us-daten komm
schon wenn lukas schenkel nicht schon
allein für dieses verbrechen den preis
für den superschurken des jahres
verdient hat ja war ihm aber nicht
sicher genug sonst wäre er wohl nicht
mit dem ultimativen bösewicht plan über
denen dieses video handelt gekommen also
nehmen wir diesen plan doch mal etwas
genauer unter die lupe
der maxwell smart als smart
bevor wir uns über diese idee des
jahrhunderts unterhalten muss ich dir
eines sagen lukaschenkos tricksereien
haben ganz eindeutig nicht nur
auswirkungen auf weißrussland bis zur
entführung des ryanair flug im mai
dieses jahres hätte niemand gedacht dass
ein europäisches land egal wie
diktatorisch regiert wird ein ziviles
verkehrsflugzeug dass sein luftraum über
fliegt auf diese weise kapern könnte
zwar gehört der luftraum über der
landmasse eines souveränen staats und
umstritten zu dessen hoheitsgebiet
rechtlich gesehen hat ein land gemäß des
chicagoer abkommen 244 also die
möglichkeit ein luftfahrzeug eines
anderen landes zu kontrollzwecken zur
landung zu zwingen allerdings ist es
dazu nur dann berechtigt wenn
ausreichende gründe vorliegen die in
diesen abkommen definiert sind und diese
gründe hat belarus einfach erfunden und
das ist dann eben missbrauch auf
allerhöchster ebene natürlich haben die
europäische union und andere nicht
tatenlos zugesehen sie haben damit
weißrussland in die internationale
terror liege eingeordnet in der etwa
gaddafis libyen oder saddam husseins er
hat gespielt haben sie haben zu schweren
sanktionen und anderen maßnahmen
betreffen der sprechen zum beispiel über
einen bahnhof für waffen und andere
güter die zur unterdrückung des eigenen
volkes verwendet werden können vor allem
aber geht es um sanktionen gegen 166
vertreter des regimes ihre guthaben sind
eingefroren und dürfen nicht in oder
durch die eu reisen natürlich ist
alexander lukaschenko selbst eine der
sanktionierten um die eu erkennt seine
regierung nun nicht mehr an
[Musik]
ich denke du christ ihr vorstellen wie
eine solche dynamik aussieht die gaddafi
oder assad ist lukaschenko quasi
international zum abschuss freigegeben
weißrussland wird dadurch noch stärker
isoliert liegen sich als reaktion ein
und macht damit einen weiteren schritt
in richtung einer perfekten diktatur
denn lukas schenkel macht schon seit
jahrzehnten das erwähne selbst wenn sein
volk die konsequenzen tragen muss aber
wenn du glaubst es einfach ist ein
diktator zu sein nächster fall schon gar
nicht wenn die eu dein nachbar ist
denn einerseits muss er das letzte wort
haben mein bild des starken mannes
abzugeben sowohl gegenüber jenen
bevölkerungsteil die ihn auch
unterstützen als auch gegenüber der
außenwelt andererseits womit kann
weißrussland überhaupt gegen die eu
auftrumpfen nun diese frage stellte sich
auch lukaschenko okay wie könnte ich die
ua taktieren um mich für die
handelssanktionen zu rechnen und sie
wenn möglich dass dazu zwingen sich mit
mehr an einen tisch zu setzen und mich
als präsident an zu erkennen kann ich
sie einfach mit meiner armee angreifen
aber nicht die haben ja vielleicht noch
die eine oder andere armee die wirklich
testen kann okay was hätten wir noch
kann ich terroristen entsenden ist ja
kein großer schritt von der luft
batterie aber nein das könnte auch ganz
schön nach hinten losgeht gut kann ich
ein handelskrieg führen wie putin einst
mit einem erdgas geht leider auch nicht
aufgepasst denn langsam nähern wir uns
den höhepunkt dieses generalistisch
diesen gedankengang und ich weiß nicht
ob lukaschenko das damen gerne mit
gesehen hat und sich für einen großen
strategen hält oder ob ihm die idee
einfach im schlaf kam aber was du gleich
sehen du wirst im echten leben passiert
schoss die ran
der weißrussische diktator droht damit
die eu mit drogen und migranten zu
überschwemmen kommt klingt das nicht die
der monolog eines klassischen
superschurken aus einem bmw allerdings
auch wenn es überraschend erscheinen mag
stellt sich heraus wenn diktator
lukaschenko etwas wirklich will ist
plötzlich nichts mehr unmöglich
[Musik]
lasst uns eine züge also mal
rekapitulieren schritt eins um einen
migrations krise zu organisieren
brauchst du als erstes die migranten
selbst nicht wahr und wenn du sie nicht
zur hand hast musst du sie der hohl und
wie in den so eine ganze werbekampagne
in ländern organisiert in denen die
menschen viele gründe haben sich auf die
socken zu machen irak syrien libanon
afghanistan und andere krisenherde um
sie zu überzeugen reichen versprechungen
wie dieser aus zu denen der
vergangenheit verbreiteten
fehlinformationen gehörte jeder
flüchtling erhält ein begrüßungsgeld von
2000 euro 2000 euro begrüßungsgeld gegen
nicht schlecht oder da hat man an diesem
versprechen dieses sollte nicht aus
lukaschenkos tasche kommen sondern aus
der des deutschen steuerzahlers
hinzu kämen noch ein garantierter
arbeitsplatz in der eu ein schönes
häuschen und so weiter und so fort und
man kennt diese unverhohlene propaganda
schon aus anderen delegationskreisen da
musste sich luca also wirklich nichts
neues einfallen lassen
[Musik]
schritt zwei ist schon etwas
komplizierter die logistik wie bringen
wir all diese wanderung willigen
menschen bis an die eu-grenze damit sie
dort das zauberwort asyl aussprechen
können ganz einfach indem wir ihnen
belarussische touristen visa ausstellen
als gäbe es kein morgen danach setzen
wir diese touristen in irische flugzeuge
die von einer weißrussischen
fluggesellschaft betrieben werden wenn
sie in weiß was drankommt bringen wir
sie zur grenze und sagen ihnen wohin sie
gehen müssen um über die grenze nach
polen und schließlich nach deutschland
zu gelangen wir wollen der zaubertrick
einen migrations krise aus dem hut zu
zaubern ist vollbracht und du das mich
fragen bist du dir sicher dass
weißrussland in bekannten wirklich aktiv
hilft an die grenze zu gelangen nun
lasst uns mal sehen helden unserer jungs
den migranten das gebiet puls zu
erreichen das ist durchaus möglich ich
denke absolut möglich
bitte auf den offenherzigen diktator
lukaschenko ist einfach verlassen herum
zu drucken und sich zu verstellen ist
nur etwas für schwache also danke für
die bestätigung locke boy übrigens keine
lukaschenko umfeld ganz ordentlich an
der ganzen geschichte zu verdienen die
migranten werden nämlich kräftig zur
kasse gebeten so arbeitet der staatliche
belarussische tourismuskonzern bei
dieser riesigen schleuser aktion ein mit
reiseveranstaltern im nahen osten
zusammen diese bringen diese touristen
dann in mit überteuerten hotels unter
deren besitzer ebenfalls gute
beziehungen zum belarussischen
präsidialamt pflegen hinzu kommen kosten
für den flug nach mist und die bezahlung
von weiteren schleuser gut jetzt weißt
du wo aus dieser masterplan besteht sagt
mir was könnte schiefgehen nun genau das
haben wir uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
der neue hybride krieg
sicher vielleicht war lukaschenko
tatsächlich davon überzeugt dass brüssel
auf der aufnahme und verteilung von
migranten und asylbewerber bestehen
polen sich aber dagegen wehren würde so
wie es sich bereits 2016 abgespielt
hatte damit sollte die spaltung der
östlichen und westlichen eu bzw der
migrations freundlichen und migrations
kritischen gesellschafts teile weiter
vorangetrieben werden yuki straube jede
menge zoff in der eu und am ende wohl
ein bürgerkrieg auf leben und tod
tatsächlich hat sich die u diesmal
jedoch als geschlossener erwiesen als
lukaschenko erwartet hätte die
europäische kommission hat 700.000 euro
für humanitäre hilfe bereitgestellt und
das rote kreuz ist im grenzgebiet tätig
geworden polen und litauen verstärkten
ihre grenzen es gibt viel raum für
verbesserungen aber zumindest im moment
de eskaliert die situation und das liegt
daran dass die eu als erstes den
migrations hahn zugedreht hat das sprach
sie mit den herkunfts und transitländern
und setzte sie zum beispiel mit der
möglichkeit unter druck
entwicklungshilfe zu streichen zweitens
hat sie auch druck auf die
fluggesellschaften ausgeübt indem sie
ihnen mit sanktionen gedroht hat
daraufhin haben transitländer wie
usbekistan die türkei oder die
vereinigten arabischen emirate begonnen
flüge nach weißrussland zu beschränken
außerdem hat die irakische regierung
flugzeuge bereit gestellt um mit der
rückführung der menschen zu beginnen bis
anfang september konnten so 2000 iraker
wieder in ihre heimat zurückkehren
hunderte von migranten kommen mit einem
flug aus weißrussland zurück in den irak
und du wirst vielleicht sagen das war es
dann wohl oder da hat sich in
weißrussland eine recht spezielle
geschichte zugetragen einzelfall der
keine auswirkungen auf den rest der welt
hat nun das stimmt leider nicht immerhin
ist es nicht das erste mal dass
migranten und asylbewerber als
politische waffe missbraucht werden und
es wird sicherlich auch nicht das letzte
mal sein
das haben wir ab 2015 er mit der türkei
und in jüngster zeit auch mit marokko
erlebt durch die türkei führte eine der
haupt migrations roten in der wanderung
welle die nachdem syrien kriegt los
wollte und genau deshalb konnte erdogan
seine bedingungen im migrations abkommen
von 2016 durchsetzen im grunde ging es
um einen haufen geld aus der eu als
gegenleistung für die kontrolle des
zugangs von migranten und asylsuchenden
in die eu heute ist das land nach wie
vor ein wichtiger torwächter so dass
sich brüssel und vor allem deutschland
als hauptziel antenne kranken von
erdogan abhängig gemacht hat ja und
dieses jahr erleben wir in spanien einen
migrations krise die von marokko
organisiert wurde einem weiteren land
das als migrations filter für europa
fungiert nach dem einsatz arosa anführer
in der nordspanischen stadt logo ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert wurde welch ein
zufall kam plötzlich tausende von
migranten nach wie utah ja wie du siehst
werden migranten und asylbewerber in der
internationalen politik tatsächlich
öfter als druckmittel eingesetzt um ganz
andere interessen durchzusetzen der
unterschied bei weißrussland es gab zwar
auch an die eu aber anders als die
türkei oder marokko befindet es sich
nicht inmitten einer geographisch
natürlichen migrations route
[Musik]
wenn es also eine sache gibt in der sich
der polnische premierminister und ursula
von leyen einig sind dann ist es die
tatsache dass lukaschenko versucht einen
übrigen krieg durch eine vollkommen
künstliche flüchtlingskrise zu
inszenieren an der so ziemlich alles
perfekt ist die frage ist also war es
das wert nun das weiß ich ja nicht okay
lukas schenkel hat ist geschafft die
aufmerksamkeit aller zu bekommen er hat
sogar zweimal mit angela merkel sprechen
dürfen aber damit enden seine vorteile
auch schon außerdem wollen wir mal sehen
was er mit den migranten macht die es
nicht nach polen schaffen aber auch
nicht in den irak zurückkehren wenn sie
in behla ausbleiben wird lukaschenko
dann sein eigenes land mit all diesen
asylsuchenden fluten der es mit der eu
wollte oder wird er sich seinem volk
dann als wertvolle bereicherung
verkaufen der aktuelle landesname ist
doch sowieso alles andere als wog aber
und russland mit einem derart radikalen
image wechsel ließ sich bestimmt so
mancher fördertopf der eu anzapfen karin
göring-eckardt freut sich schon darauf
aber die fördergelder wird lukaschenko
auch brauchen denn sein land verfügt
nicht über genügend ressourcen um all
diese migranten irgendwie zu integrieren
vor allem die anspruchsvollen unter
ihnen die sich gastfreundschaft auf
deutschem niveau erhofft haben
freilich gibt es in minsk auch keinen
deutschen arbeitsmarkt der nach
facharbeitern dürstet aber wie dem auch
sei wir werden genauestens beobachten
wie sich die ereignisse in den kommenden
monaten entwickeln da geht also bitte
nicht visuell politik zu abonnieren weil
sie das nicht schon längst getan hast
aber jetzt wie frage an dich was hältst
du von lukaschenkos planen lässt du
weitere beispiele in denen migranten als
waffen eingesetzt werden und wie würdest
du an der stelle der eu handeln wie
immer sind auf eure meinung zu diesem
thema hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt es mit einem like heißt mit
euren freunden
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
kann unsere videos mehr zu verpassen und
unterstützt unsere arbeit wird auch mit
einer kleinen spende über den link in
der beschreibung unter diesem video
macht gut bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]